on va pleurer on va rire on va kiffer
oui mon mathieu excusez moi ok fia ce
qui la ferme et honnête en direct oui 6
passes
si je suis ici mais il veut il veut
fêter un petit peu l'amour s'attelle
maintenant faisant toi et moi tu vois
pas de shampooing en prime je t'ai déjà
je suis en clientèle et la musique et
non mais tu vois que je suis en
clientèle là ça fait chier de l'usure je
t'ai déjà dit dans mon lieu de travail
mon coeur ça fait deux ans maintenant
c'est vrai qu'on vit quelque chose de
très très fort oui deux parfois trois
quand ta femme qui est charmante
également vous parle de l'amour bien sûr
alors si tu le permets comme c'est la
saint valentin c'est l'amour n'était en
direct moi aussi je voulais faire un
petit cadeau c'est pour toi
[Musique]
jean torero tu veux être mon petit
taureau olé tu me dit regardez
[Musique]
autour ne suffirait pas vous avoir 6
c'est pas mal
du port est à bout de bras qu'est ce
qu'il a la maman qui nous met pas
toujours été sûr
moi il a sa couleur bordeaux on dirait
une bouteille d'eau envie de faire péter
le bouchon
et parce que je ferai
joie
et on est comme ça tout comme europe ses
roues qui ont du cash
comme on a tous envie est pas tout ce
que des médiatiquement serait tellement
bien
[Musique]
on dirait
à vous tous et maman ouais je veux dire
l'amitié qui entre nous me touche
beaucoup
nous restons des métiers dire qu'on se
voit beaucoup oui oui parfois même nous
sommes si peu engueulé ça peut arriver
ses toiles à saissac important ça mais
en vrai je dire la vérité je t'aime très
fort voilà les faits avec ce mot ami non
mais vraiment ça me touche je te jure
ben ouais saint valentin mocanu non mais
arrêtez avec ça